that that's
where where come from me not being
back to these messages specifically they
have to be the starting point
>> that's what we do so everywhere
everywhere but generally speaking we're
in London cuz I'm from London they have
suffered very similar to this same
cases. Okay. So that's why they they go
out there to people try to remove the
doubts that Islam support
and just uh like oppressing women and so
on. But also the most important aspect
that we are here for to connect people
to the creator.
>> Like you know you want to worship God
correct?
>> You want to worship God.
>> Yeah. You want to be grateful to him.
Okay.
>> But now, like I said, you want to do it,
you wait for his way.
>> His way.
>> So, how do you know what you're doing
now? That's his way.
>> And God, the most wise will not leave us
in confusion without clarified truth.
That's why we go truth prophets and
messages. That's why I spoke about Anak.
What was his what is his prophecy? What
is his his
criteria to be to claim to be from God
in the clearly he stole from the Quran
got a clear verse from the Quran he
mixed it he see so and now when you
speak about I want to worship God
correctly now what is the correct way
the correct way the truth that's why
when God choose prophets and messengers
he gave them what they came with the
same teaching look to Moses worship one
god who is the god of Abraham and Adam
Okay.
>> Jeremiah, Daniel, Jesus, Prophet
Muhammad, all of them called people to
worship God.
>> Okay. So, when you look to the prophets
and messengers according to the Old
Testament, the New [clears throat]
Testament and Islam, they never met each
other, but they spread the same thing.
Worship the God of Abraham. Okay? And
again, if I establish Prophet Muhammad
as a true prophet, then whatever oppose
Prophet Muhammad's teaching must be
forced because God will never tell us
the truth and he will give someone else
another truth that oppose that truth.
That doesn't make any sense and God is
the most wise. You understand?
>> Thank you very much for listening to me.
>> I have been given my friends.
>> Sorry, forgive me man. But let me give
you something to read. Please take this.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Show me the way.
>> And this is my friend.
>> Thank you very much.
Have a nice weekend.
>> All right.
>> You want to round that one up from?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, because you came late,
my brother, you see, that's why you
cannot trust Jamaican.
[laughter]
So alhamdulillah this guy uh this
gentleman uh he's sik you know
>> uh so I was speaking to about sikism how
can you how can you prove to me that cuz
remember gonag disappeared for a few
days he came back not Islam not Hinduism
or something and I said how can you
worship god according to sikism teaching
>> okay
>> how can you establish that sikism
teaching is from god
>> okay
>> you understand so he couldn't all right
and he said rather what they believe
that there's no absolute truth. So I
told him that statement there's no
absolute truth. Is it absolute truth or
not?
>> So you know you can see was sincere
inshallah was honest. He was not
fighting back to looking for any
argument to reject the truth.
>> Then alhamdulillah when he noticed that
he cannot prove what he believes. So as
explained to him what Islam is, what
Islam is the truth and about prophet
Muhammad about his legislation
prophecies in the Quran and so on. So
alhamdulillah he was listening. May
Allah guide him.
>> Amen. Amen. Everything.